the queen
on the balcony and having all those
people out there to welcome
she should have rightly felt you know
very proud about that moment and uh i
think that just in the way the whole
country feels proud about our queen and
how she served us in is such a an
amazing way for 70 years
how did you feel about the prime
minister being booed
well okay um i didn't i i saw the clips
of that afterwards either there were
booze there were cheers but look no no
politician is uh universally loved it
won't be the first time a a politician
is booed in it and uh
there'll be there'll be you know much of
that for many politicians down the line
i think that uh uh it's a
you know people are perfectly entitled
to their views but what's more important
is to have a prime minister that's uh
getting on with the job that's
delivering uh for the country and that's
exactly what we have
54 letters needed to trigger a
confidence vote in him um are you
expecting that threshold to be reached
look i i don't know
that's the honest answer no one knows at
this point apart from sir graham brady
my colleague who is the the chair of the
what's called the 1922 committee we know
that a number of colleagues have already
you know gone public with uh asking for
such a vote that's a that's a decision
of course uh for them if 54 letters are
reached i'm sure a vote will be called i
i do think it's possible uh but i don't
know
um i was reading in the guardian this
morning a senior mp
saying uh about the mood of the
constituents because of course a lot of
mps have been asking about in their
constituencies given the four-day bank
holiday weekend for the platinum jubilee
saying i'm getting people coming up to
me and
greeting me with that smile and that
tilt of the head that's usually reserved
when your labrador puppy has just been
run over
goodness
look uh the the
i i i think the
this country doesn't need a vote of
confidence in the prime minister uh i
think what we need to be doing as a
country is is certainly looking ahead to
the the challenges that exist you know
i'm here today at kingston hospital uh
standing behind this brand new scanner
by the way there i want to talk to you
about that in just a second but i just
want to deal with party gate and then
i'm going to come back to that if i may
i'll give you plenty of time to talk
about while you're in kingston but while
i while we're still talking about the
popularity of the prime minister there
was a weekend poll uh which was released
ahead of the wakefield by-election
and that's just in a couple of weeks
time isn't it i don't know if you've
seen it but it makes very very very
unhappy reading for the prime minister
this morning
look i i saw that uh poll and uh the
there were particular circumstances the
resignation of the former uh mp in in
wakefield and
frankly i'm not surprised by what i
saw and what i read some of the detail
around that poll but the only poll
that's going to matter is the one on the
23rd of june both for wakefield and also
tiverton and hollington you know i was
in tibetan and horriton on on saturday
with helen herford our a fantastic
candidate there and certainly on the
doors that i knocked on there was there
was lots of support
especially because there was chatting to
me as the health secretary around our
vaccination program which has been world
leading the record investment that we're
making uh in the nhs the record
increases in the nhs workforce the the
adult social care plans came up and how
we're tackling those for the first time
we have a prime minister who's willing
to tackle that so you know they're there
let's see what happens on the 23rd of
june to fight elections you need money
uh lord michael torres said he'll refuse
to make further donations unless boris
johnson is removed from office
look he's entitled to his view and every
political party uh has has has its
donors and
i am confident that i speak to donors or
potential donors to the conservative
party uh many times and i know that many
of them are fully behind the prime
minister and our program for delivery
you know that's what motivates them what
people look at whether they're donors or
ordering people what they look at is is
is delivery we i'm standing here right
now as i say in this hospital that's
getting record investment our economy as
well we have the lowest unemployment
rate in almost uh 50 years and uh of
course we've got challenges especially
cost of living challenges the covered
backlogs but this is a government that's
getting on with the job and that's what
i think people expect politicians to
focus on a member circulating over the
weekend calling the prime minister the
conservative corbyn
what do you make of that
well this prime minister is the one that
to save the country from corbynism if
you look back at that 2019 election
there was a very real prospect that
labor under jeremy corbyn could have won
instead this prime minister delivered
the the biggest majority that the
conservatives have seen uh since
margaret thatcher's time and and and
used that majority to deliver for this
country you're delivering on brexit
getting on with dealing with the
pandemic look did we get every decision
right the prime minister's been very
honest about this especially when it
came to the pandemic we didn't get every
decision right not er no leader in the
world was able to deal with the global
pandemic and get every decision right
but we got the big decisions right and
now in the aftermath of this pandemic
again use the health and social care
secretary i'm very focused on on both of
those you're getting our health system
back up and running back to normal
dealing with those backlogs but also on
adult social care you know delivering
with a reform plan for the first time
putting in extra billions but also
leading to better integration between
health and social care that's what
people want us that's just the kind of
thing they want us to focus on
yeah but it he's so fabulous this prime
minister why is he about to face
reverting her confidence
look
as i say that whether there's a vote of
uh confidence or not that's a decision
uh for my colleagues and and and you
know no no prime minister no leader of
the conservative party as far as i'm
aware of has enjoyed a 100 percent
support of uh colleagues you know where
democratic party uh we're actually the
most successful democratic party in the
western world and and and and what part
of that strength comes from having
differences of opinion at some times and
and we have processes so you know if a
if this threshold of 54 letters is
reached there will be a confidence vote
and in that case of course there should
be there may well be one if there is the
prime minister uh will will will fight
and uh and stand his corner with a very
very strong case so let's just wait and
see what happens
uh tell me about the scanner
well this is uh
as i said this is kingston hospital i'm
at today this is a brand new ct scan i
think the third one in this particular
hospital is part of our plan to invest
billions in dealing with those uh
coveted backlogs we've opened up in in
since the pandemic some 90 what we call
the community diagnostic centers these
are the new one-stop shops for
scans and tests and and checkups in the
most convenient of locations we're going
to have 160 of these in total over the
next couple of years and together they
will deliver some nine million more you
know tests and scans and checkups you're
freeing up nhs capacity this is just one
example of how we're trying to deal with
the backlog but also with the backlog
itself we're making some good progress i
think it's fair to say on dealing with
waiting times those waiting the longest
that number has been halved in in the
last four months so thanks to the the
plans that we've got but thanks most of
all to the efforts of all the staff that
are working across the nhs and i want to
take this opportunity to thank them
again for everything that they are doing
working day in day out to deliver for
patients across england
the royal college of nursing says that
on their last shift 80 percent of nurses
say that staffing levels were not
sufficient to meet the needs of patients
we do need more nurses and that is why
we set out a plan at that last election
of 50 000 more nurses we've got 30 000
already just in the last year despite
the pandemic and the challenges i think
of the last year we've added 2
400 more nurses and by the way we've
also added over 4 000 doctors so we are
increasing the nhs workforce it is
challenging we need more doctors and
nurses
and we are recruiting at the highest
levels ever we've got more people
working in the nhs than ever before and
we've got more nurses in training
doctors in trading than ever before
we're pulling every lever to to get the
workforce that we need
okay what was your favorite moment of
the uh jubilee celebrations if you don't
say the queen on the balcony paddington
bear or prince louis then you're never
coming back
i my my favorite moment actually was
paddington bear hey i i i i i couldn't
but i couldn't believe it and uh nawk of
my kids like i couldn't believe it but
it just it just sort of goes to show you
that you know just how amazing our queen
is that she was able to surprise us
including
as i understand it her own family uh
with that very what i thought was just a
magical moment that will live with us
forever
yeah we're out of time but we just want
to show this uh to our viewers which you
shared uh on your instagram feed this
was you at the silver jubilee in 1977
like it was yesterday eh
yeah i i i love that picture i was in
two minds whether i should
tweet it out or not i showed it to my
wife and she said look get it out there
you haven't changed and uh and i think
many of us will probably have moments
like that especially if you were lucky
to be alive in 1977 and see the silver
jubilee as well and to and to think now
you know so many years on our queen is
still there and has achieved so much
more